- [Instructor] We are
asked, what is a reasonable
estimate for the limit of g
of x as x approaches three?
So what we have here in
blue, this is the graph
of y is equal to g of x,
and we wanna think about
what is the limit as x approaches three,
so this is x equals three here.
So what you need to do is,
think about what is the
limit of this function
as we approach three from the left,
and we're also gonna think about
what is the limit of this function,
what does it appear to be from the graph,
as we approach this value from the right.
And if it looks like we're
approaching the same value,
then that would be a reasonable
estimate for the limit,
and the reason why they
say reasonable estimate
is 'cause we're gonna do it by inspection.
We don't have a lot more
information about the graph
to know for sure, but from the graph,
we can come up with a reasonable estimate.
So pause this video and see
if you can figure it out
on your own.
Alright, so let's think
about it in two parts.
Let's think about
approaching x equals three,
or let's think about the
limit as x approaches three
from the left, as we approach
x equals three from the left.
So as we approach x equals
three from the left,
our graph seems to be, our graph seems to,
if I just eyeball it,
seems to be approaching
the value four.
So from the left, it looks
like we are approaching four.
Approaching, or let me write it this way,
g of x approaching four.
G of x approaching four,
as x approaches three from the left.
Now let's think about it from the right.
As x approaches three from the right,
what does it look like
g of x is approaching?
Well, it looks like g of x is
approaching negative three,
as x approaches three from the right.
So I could say, g of x approaching,
approaching negative three
as x approaches three
from the right.
And so we have two different values here.
When we approach from the left,
it looks like g of x is approaching four,
and when we approach from the right,
it looks like g of x is
approaching negative three.
And so because of that, we would say
that this limit right over here,
it's reasonable to say that
this limit doesn't exist.
So I'll write, does not exist,
based on looking at this
graph right over here.
And a good clue that it won't exist
is the x value where we're
trying to find the limit at,
you see this jump in the
graph right over here,
it is discontinuous, it jumps
from one value to another,
which is a good clue that the
limit might not exist here.